[Music]
the first thing is that in this hybrid
cloud transformation in reality we are
seeing multiple transformations at the
same time and that makes it even more
complicated the first one is this notion
that applications are evolving very fast
we are all used to
maybe monolithic applications living
inside VMs or iteration all bare-metal
servers running well establish a
plication x' but at the same time there
is a new transformation towards cloud
native what we start developing with
containers with past frameworks using
such services from Google cloud from
Salesforce from were they and now we
have to figure out a way to put
everything together and this happens not
on a confined location in four walls in
the data center but now happens in a
wall that is much more difficult happens
across multiple geographies multiple
clouds multiple offices multiple
branches and now you have to figure out
a way how to solve those problems when
you have various applications that they
have to communicate between the ones
that have been there for 20 years
to the ones that are being designed
right now you have a problem of
portability as you refresh data centers
as you go to different clouds as you go
to different substrates how do you do
that in order to keep your applications
running with the level of the slate that
you require and then all these combined
with the fact that you have to secure it
how do you secure it across multiple
locations there's multiple clouds across
multiple geographies especially when you
have to think in terms of regulations
compliance data governance so it's it's
very complicated and here we are just
talking about application evolution but
what about data when an application
touches a user that is connecting to an
app and generate some data where do you
store the data
what kind of regulations what kind of
compliance do you have to forget about
this data how do you track it so it's
it's quite complicated so now what
happened though is that as we were going
through this journey the infrastructure
has to start changing and adjusting to
this new reality and traditionally we
were used to think in terms of compute
storage and networking we put the
substrate of infrastructure with
the most solid and capable
infrastructure that we can create then
we build applications on top of that and
we open tickets in order to adjust
infrastructure to those applications and
so on so we were always building the
house by the foundation starting by
solid principles of infrastructure but
that doesn't work anymore when I have an
application running in Google Cloud
Europe another one on on brandy sphere
on your data center on the US how do I
do that how do I start from the
foundation if I don't understand what's
the use case that is going to drive that
infrastructure so what happen over the
last few years is that the driving force
of infrastructure became the application
so now instead of thinking how do I
create the best networking that I can
afford I start thinking how do I have a
network infrastructure that
automatically adjusts to the application
needs and these stars by having an adder
brutalization substrate that works
across multiple environments that now
through automation allows through CSE
these pipelines and processes to
constantly create a network that needs
application and then of course working
across multiple branches multiple
locations and that enables cognitive and
we'll talk some of these things how they
fit together
the next is even more difficult because
as we go through an application
transformation and different substrates
private cloud public cloud now the
question is who's managing that what's
the expertise of the teams managing that
how do they work together so always
remember that it's not just about
technology any transformation especially
one as because as the one that we are
living right now with the movement of
multi cloud to cloud and the notion of
cloud native applications is how these
principles are developed all the DevOps
teams the IT teams security teams how
are they going to work together in this
new environment that is much more
distributed much more decentralized so
essentially we need to figure out a way
how do we retrain our organizations or
teams in order to work together what
type of tools are they going to use what
processes how to adjust the processes
and how to have an end-to-end visibility
that a problem that happens in a
production environment and the DevOps
team realizes about that gets correlated
to the security guys when a big
it's applied in a way that compliant
source always maintained always thing
it's not just the technology transition
is about how do we bring this technology
movement into other organizations and
how do we train our teams to be able to
operate on that so to that extent we
started working with Google and we're
saying look we share this passion and
this energy to store saying how do we
help our customers to drive the best out
of the infrastructure that they have
regardless if it's public cloud with
Google Cloud or vSphere environments
with VMware technologies the thing is
how do you provide kind of this seamless
interaction between private and public
in a way that you don't have to worry
about the complexities of establishing
connectivity you have the ability to
essentially create applications that can
move between private and public based on
what do you need to have them what is
more efficient to have them or you have
the ability to essentially discover what
I said do you have how do you connect
them how do you track them how do you
observe them in a way that now
essentially we provide some sort of an
enterprise solution that makes this a
reality that can be addressed and ported
into into to these environments so this
is how we started the journey working
together and now we are going to go
through some of the use cases and
problems that we encounter along the way
and some of the work we are doing in
order to solve them so I'm going to pass
it - Thank You Barry
yeah so as Perry mention there is a lot
in common that we have Department of
solving some of the use cases for for
the customer so let me give you a little
bit of perspective of what we see from
Google cloud and what are the type of
problems that our customers are coming
with so there is obviously a lot of
opportunities for innovation by
consuming Google cloud services so in
different verticals and in different
industries there are different uses for
how to get more insight of the data more
signals real-time visibility into the
data that the enterprise are generating
in financial services we're seeing a lot
of enterprises that want to have more
advanced mathematical algorithms and and
models we see a lot in retail and in
industrial to really transform their
business by starting to analyze their
data they're generating by training
machine learning model for example with
with the cloud we see a lot of
healthcare opportunities for providing
better research and provide as well a
better capabilities for real-time
interaction hospital in hospital
communication and finally in industrial
and manufacturing there are many use
cases for providing better supply chains
results by getting analytics of the data
warehouse that gets generated as part of
the supply chain I've been able to
understand the Falls and improve the
quality on some of those supply chains
capabilities in order to do that
customers are need to communicate to
Google services they need to send some
of the data to Google services they need
to be able to ingest the data and send
back results that are meaningful for
those use cases in real time and as it
is a simple example to think about
connectivity to the cloud we will see
that the complexity associated of
managing and securing that communication
and the underlying data that is so
important to the enterprises and
managing the services on top of that it
is really challenged in a really a
problem that we won't solve together so
the first thing that we encounter when
we're actually going for this for
solving this use cases is the
connectivity to
to the cloud so we we need to make sure
that we simplify we secure the
connectivity to the cloud and in order
to do so we're partnering with VMware
with their being where is the one by
Bello cloud solution so if you can
imagine you know now you have your data
centers tens of data centers you have
thousands of branches and then you
really want to get advantage of all
those new capabilities and innovation in
the cloud you need to start setting up
that connectivity for setting up that
connectivity and onboard those services
for your enterprise and your developers
and your DevOps to use you need to start
setting up VPN and then you can think of
that as an N squared problem you need to
start setting up connectivity from any
of those branches any of those data
centers to your cloud and set up
point-to-point connectivities you need
to go and set up your firewalls and then
you need to configure those on your
branches and data centers then you need
to go to the cloud and understand what
the segmentation is across make sure
that the configuration is done correctly
and then you need to secure the data you
need to make sure that the access to the
data is really only accessible from
users and locations that are allowed on
they are authorized to access it and you
can imagine now if you actually have a
global deployment and then you need to
have geographical considerations for
where your applications are sitting and
where your data is sarena how you access
those you need to set up additional
policies in order to enforce those so it
is a very complex on board for
onboarding but I think it is even more
complex to maintain and operate because
then you need to actually have a mapping
of your configurations in the cloud and
in on-prem and then you need to
be able to operate good visibility and
manage that securely without very
fragmented view of the wall in your
private and in your public cloud so in
order to do that we want to do better we
want to make sure that we're enterprise
customers hardware ways of doing that
and we think it's possible and pretty
going going to walk us through how we
actually simply find that journey and
that operation thank you so the next was
mentioning we were looking at the
problem from the different side but we
were having customers coming to us and
saying look I want to connect to Google
cloud and I have all these problems the
VPN so far was the geolocation how can
we solve that and when we started to
talk to Google it was kind of a perfect
match because what we saw is that the
problem that Google was saying is how to
accelerate the eruption of cloud and the
customers that we are having saying how
do i connect to cloud we managed to
essentially work together to create a
solution and the technology we use is
the NSX sd1 by Vela cloud it's a nasty
one technology that the way it works is
on the far left we have what we call an
edge and this is a managed service
that's essentially the only thing you
have to do is you get one of these edge
appliances you connect it to your
location connects automatically to your
castrator and that's it now you go to
the orchestrator anka you can manage
your global network of all the branches
that you have as if it was a single
entity and in there you can set global
policies in terms of security in terms
of connectivity in terms of application
SLA and the se1 solution what it does
essentially is constantly monitors the
flow of data traffic going from the edge
to any other location in this case going
through what we call a gateway a cloud
gateway that the green box in the middle
or two other edges and now it provides
you a central view of this square
problem that Ennis was mentioning before
and when and then your start reasoning
in terms of how do I provide an SLA
policy for a specific app that needs to
be grantee three others on where it
talks to how do I provide a virtual
segment that is going to essentially
isolate a component of the traffic
needs to talk to a critical part of my
applications in the backend or it needs
to talk across different branches how do
I set up security policies but you do it
at the orchestrator level without having
to worry about the specifics of the site
where you may have to manage that now
what we did with Google we started
working on how to connect the sd1
technology by VMware to the Google
capabilities and we are going to explain
it in the next slide but basically you
see that there's multiple ways to
connect the sd1 technology to the cloud
one is using the Gateway capabilities to
VPN into native cloud services and this
is one integration we've done with
Google but there's other ways that we
are exploring that are much more
efficient in terms of how to put a
branch capability inside that vault
itself in a way that now you have a
native connectivity to the VPC or to the
element that you want to have in the
Google cloud so with this background
what we did is we started working with
Google Dwarfs connecting as I was
mentioning all the sites click 'add as
if they were data centers running
applications or branches needed to
connect to the applications not only to
the private cloud but to the public
cloud and by rating with the Google VPN
capabilities now we provided a global
bill with the NSX as the one
Orchestrator to essentially manage the
connectivity has a capability as a
service so we went from having to manage
thousands of VPN points thousands of
firewall rules trying to understand in
what location the closest Google service
would be to just a simple check that you
say enable TCP core activity and problem
solved and then of course you can go
into a more granular way about defining
application essays and security policies
we are going to see a very quick demo of
this in a second but later we can get
into details and explain you more about
how this work so this was one of the
major problems that Ennis was mentioning
how to connect to the Google cloud
services with a single point of
management but more important was cloud
is not an aesthetic thing you keep
deploying more applications you have
your CSV pipelines you have your
production systems you have your PCI
compliant systems you have different
environments that constantly grow and
shrink the nature of qualities that you
don't have a set of
predefined IP addresses or predefined
resources what you do is like
essentially you grow and shrink as
needed you the poem or environment as
needed so thus the day-to-day
operational aspect is essentially were
the significant advantage towards
customers work roaming it was not just
how to onboard the cloud is how to more
the cloud and constantly maintain it as
applications were coming and going and
growing and shrinking in the club so
this was the first part of the
collaboration and after 13 years all the
problems were solving we could go home
right yeah not so fast yet still
problems to resolve so there are of
course you know the connectivity it is
the connectivity aspect of it on
onboarding and maintaining as perry was
mentioning but there are additional use
cases now as enterprises and you guys
are totally familiar with this you
onboard cloud and then you start
deploying applications on services where
there are opportunities but there are
reasons why certain applications on
services need to remain on frame and
those could be because practical reasons
you know it's not possible to with
platform those or it could be because of
regulatory reasons or location reasons
for latency needs that those services
need to be localized so what we see is
that really this creates close
dependencies of applications that need
to be read that need to stay on prem and
then services that will be on boarded in
cloud another example that is for
example CI CD deployments that happen in
cloud in order to get advantage of the
flexibility of those environments but
you want to deploy the images to your
applications that are running on
premises so all these really creates
really truly a mesh of applications that
need to communicate to be secure and to
which we we need to really control the
communication the authentication and we
need to get visibility about the
performance and the the way these
applications talk to each other so in
order to do that we have a bigger or
another big problem to solve which is
the ability to really federate the
communication and the management of
these services in a way that is seamless
across both environments and there is
significant effort that being where
Anna's are driving together in which we
have a common vision on how we're going
to feather rate this service in a way
that can't be operated in an easy way
and a simplified way for our enterprise
customers from Google perspective if you
yes came from the keynote you saw that
we have announced Google clouds and
those in GA I want to talk a little bit
about what we do in terms of modernize
and and building a cloud services
platform at Google we obviously have had
a lot of experience already in
kubernetes environments we have had for
years now the google kubernetes engine
on the cloud which is a managed platform
in which we actually solve the problem
for developers but we also solve the
problem of the platform of the platform
operator in which we how to upgrade the
node we maintain we out to scale will
repair so we really seen our value as
not only solving the developer problem
but also the administrative platform
operator problem and really fully given
manage platform for kubernetes what we
have done is we have expanded to on
premises with DKA on Prem and we really
remain with the same values on value
prop and providing a manit's
platform for kubernetes in um frame
following the same principles that we
had in cloud and on top of that we build
value and we are providing control
playing capabilities with go from you
know cluster register and management
being able to authentically the cluster
so that we can actually manage and
operate it
we provide visibility with the
integration of a stock driver with logs
we are as well providing config
management capabilities so that the
configuration of the different services
and clusters can be done from a
centralized place we have build as well
marketplace platform so that the
kubernetes applications not only for our
words but for third parties can be
imported and consumed by our customers
in a seamless way and finally and this
is the part in which you know we're
going to talk more today's we have an
East your service management that we are
providing for managing and operating the
service mess of the services and in this
specific area is where we are
collaborating very closely with with
VMware to provide solution of the
operational management of those services
I want to guess highlight that really
the vision that we have is build on the
open source capabilities at these
various layers like it anchors on the
kubernetes for orchestrating work loss
it anchors in sto for the service
management and we really have a common
view of how we can actually made those
open source manage value at on both
sides work together seamlessly to solve
the problem of the service management
and with that I want to
half periods well talking more about how
we'll actually federal rate in both
environments so basically this was
mentioning what we started seeing is
that a lot of our customers were
starting to expand the footprint where
they would develop those services by the
foundation of cover Nettie's we saw
great traction on how to create micro
services and we started seeing that
because of the footprint the agility the
ability to essentially sunshade them
grow them seeing them we started see a
proliferation of kubernetes environments
in the enterprise of course we have pkas
kubernetes service for the vSphere
environment that we are deploying in
data centers but we started to see
kubernetes appearing in the branches I
mean there's a lot of retailers looking
on how to modernize the retail
experience I put in digital signage
points of present detection of who's
coming to the store and customizing the
behavior of the stores based on who you
are so that requires some lightweight
form of compute that would be very agile
so this is what we started seeing all
these kubernetes services everywhere and
now as nessarose mentioning this is a
different problem now we are not talking
about connectivity from the point of
view of IP connectivity application as
list but now we are saying why this
application should be talking to your
back-end database is this application of
production environment is this a
development environment is this
application connecting to the database
on behalf of a user so the problems went
a little bit higher where now we were
not talking about connectivity from
networking point of view but we started
to see the problems of identity the
problems of understanding what
applications are doing on behalf of the
users that they have connected to the
application what did the elements do you
touch so as the next thing we start to
look at this problem a couple of years
ago and we were saying okay this is
going to be a new wave of things that we
have to work with enterprises to solve
them and we started to work around the
project of this year and amboy in a way
to be able to solve that but there was
this problem of okay so I have multiple
kubernetes environments I could create
what's called a service mess in each of
those environments where now we have the
ability to connect
a service to another service and
understand what API calls what
authentication events or through session
all these things but it would be
confined to every single location and
enterprises don't want that they want to
have a game a common way to understand
federated identity authentication
authorization data access so we had this
gap in between the multiple coverage
environments the service is running in
the cloud and we had to figure out how
to solve and how to bridge that so
within this we started working on this
project
NSX service mass which is a project that
we are developing and now we are in
better States but we are going to
announce it soon as fully available that
essentially was the ability to
essentially control what we call a data
plane inside the kubernetes environment
based on HTML voice and be able to
control through the service that we are
getting on top many of them and the idea
is that from this vantage point we have
the ability to essentially discover all
the services that running in the
communities environments then once you
discover them understand how are they
performing what are they doing what's
their SL is a loss and be able to react
based on that after that essentially
focus on how to control them how to put
security policies how to put application
level policies and getting into the
security aspect that we are discussing
on how to have an understanding of
security and one within these Google was
working on answers and we were saying
well I mean we have common goals we are
all trying to solve the notion of how
enterprises are going to lose services
across clouds in a centralized way that
now identity policy visibility
observability are going to be consistent
because at the end of the day is all
about operations about how to keep your
applications running regardless of where
they are so within this environment
again we went back to the drawing board
and we said well Google is providing
eastern employee base capabilities in
their decay environment we are working
with our kubernetes environments and
providing is to avoid capabilities or if
the control planes that we have
developed would start to further rate
between ourselves in a way that now from
customer experience what you have
essentially is an end-to-end mess
of micro-services talking to each other
regardless if they are native in cloud
in public cloud or riding on your
branches or your private cloud they all
form part of and to enmesh now of course
that's easier said than done because in
reality there's many more things needed
in the sense that we have to create the
ability to create manage like domains or
global namespaces in a way that not all
the services talk to each other
you're going to have production
applications you are going to have
development environments you're going to
have sensitive things so it's not just a
flat and to a mess
but it's what we are doing with Google
is bringing the capabilities on top of
the open source component that we are
developing about how to make it work for
enterprises how to provide a proper
level of segmentation how to provide the
proper level of visibility essentially
the nsx service mesh control element
federates with the anthers controller
you know whether now we can have a
federated identity that when a service
on prem talks to a service in the cloud
now we maintain the end-to-end
properties of that communication being
able to have sensually mostly
authenticated TLS sessions with a proper
level of encryption authentication
authorization and so on so that was
going up the stack how to go from the
connectivity plane that we provide in
the previous example and now go one
level above and start to get into the
notion of what our applications doing on
behalf of whom and what data elements
really touch and to end across multiple
clouds so that's the nature of the
cooperation of course we are going
through a journey and what we started
working on is essentially this is the
high-level overview of the project so we
have kubernetes environments by vmware
PKS on Prem
control by service mess and then we have
G key classes running kubernetes and
talking to Google native services with
an first controlling this and we started
essentially controlling the
interoperability of services talking
from private to public cloud and
visa-versa
at the federation level with end-to-end
most foully authenticated here sessions
that's the part that we are
demonstrating right now we are going to
show some little video and if you want
more details in the booth later but the
word doesn't
here of course now we have to go to the
next level of saying sure I could
further it identity I could further it
into an encryption but what about
coordinating policies because now you're
going to have a set of hierarchies of
policies organizations groups roles and
so on on the cloud you are going to have
another one on the on Prem now the idea
is how to bring all these things
together so take this collaboration as
the starting point of solving this
problem still lots of work to do so
we'll continue to work as the project
evolves with Google but the angle
essential is to allow and to
invisibility connectivity security
policy compliance between public and
private at the service level
understanding from user services and
data and when so with this maybe let's
talk a little bit about the work with it
yeah so by the way we're going to show a
quick demo video please step by the
booths really to get more information on
more details this is just a quick
snapshot there is a lot more data that
can be made available to you there just
to quickly set the stage I just want to
recap a little bit of the challenge
about the challenges that we're going to
about to demonstrate and just to really
get a view of what those challenges are
just imagine business transformation for
a retailer and you know the journey that
they go through they might have checkout
payment shipment you know services that
it's a monolithic running in on-prem and
then they start moving some of the
capabilities to cloud you know for the
flexibility the pay as you grow the
front-end capabilities of the cloud so
in this case they're moving catalogs so
as you are actually doing that then you
face the problem of connectivity that's
not how we started actually discussing
in the session and you need to make sure
that your branches get connected to to
the cloud and you need to connect those
applications on top of that and now
imagine that you're actually breaking
the monolithic that you have on prim and
then you start creating micro services
that are some pieces of the monolithic
that you had before so for example
you'll break in payments and shipments
but really all these applications need
to communicate with each other there are
dependencies there's data that they need
to share that state or there is some
type of communication that needs to
happen you still need to have the
communication to the cloud and then you
want complexity with the communication
of the applications on top of it on Prem
and in cloud and as you go through the
transformation you see opportunities for
getting my more insight of your data for
example in your branches and you see an
opportunity or having data image
recognition in the branches and for
example having email train models that
you are running in cloud in which you
can extract meaningful information real
time in your branches what that requires
is of course the underlying connectivity
but it also creates additional
dependencies of your communication of
applications from own services and to
cloud and so on keeps growing you then
you know recommendation or you want to
do ad insertion to add value to your
business and all that really what it
creates and this is just a sample it is
a very complicated relationship of
services that have dependencies among
each other so the key is how do you
secure operate how in this environment
you make sure that for example your dev
environments are not talking to your
production environments that there is no
data that is crossing boundaries that is
not safe the observability and security
of these deployments is challenging
unless you have a way of actually having
a single view of this and a single
operation across all these deployments
and this is really what we want to talk
about in the in the video so with that
as one to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in hybrid clouds
and as it is we're saying this is just a
quick kind of high-level marketing video
about some of the things we've done but
we encourage everybody to go to the
VMware booth and maybe to the Google
booth where we have live demos with
mites more detail in terms of how from
an SD one how do you import aside how to
connect to Google how do you set the
policies the applications are silly and
so on
and with the nsx service managed
connected to anther 0c the same how do I
discover the connectivity matrix how do
I see how services are performing how do
I understand the relations between them
and how does it do the end-to-end
Federation with MPLS we just wanted to
summarize essentially the two problems
that we've been working together to
solve and essentially this notion that
when you have hybrid cloud solutions
it's relatively well understood how to
provision services in the cloud how to
provision services on them but those
need to communicate together because we
don't have applications that they don't
interact we have the payment systems
with the front-end and things like that
so the idea was how to first start by
addressing secure connectivity between
private cloud and public cloud
regardless on the many offices many
brands as many sites you may have but
then the next was to emphasize this
notion that the wall is moving very fast
and it's not just about how to provide
secure connectivity but how to get into
the fabric of what the application is
doing and if we don't understand we
don't secure we don't control what
applications are doing what users are
doing with these applications and what
data elements are being touched
means that we don't really have control
and visibility of infrastructure and
this is the idea that we have to get
into the service mess fabric or the
business fabric of the communications
that enable us to since you now take
control at the behavior level at the SLA
level at the security level of what
applications do and this is essentially
what drove
VMware and Google working together and
as summer essentially we were saying in
order to enable our customers
enterprises to essentially achieve a
true hybrid broad story with star by
connectivity and application level qss
but essentially we have to go to service
management and understand the end-to-end
because at the end of the day this is
just again infrastructure we are not
doing
director for the sake of infrastructure
but essentially to enable enterprises to
innovate to become more agile to become
faster to deliver new value to their
customers and this essentially has to be
done while maintaining the
enterprise-class capabilities of being
able to operate it with the security
grantees and the visibility elements
that the operational environments of
enterprises may need so as a summary I
wanted to emphasize what eNOS was saying
that the two companies are working
together and very committed to the
openness or framers that we are using we
are working a lot on the public domain
doing contributions around East here and
boy kubernetes and some of the projects
associated to that because this is kind
of a true community effort that as the
Federation element of multiple collage
work together it has to be built out of
common standards and the common
standards right now are being built out
of open source frameworks the aura
nation is this shared vision of saying
this is not about what's right is it
public cloud is it private cloud is it
something else it's this this phase is
gone it's not about where things should
go but is how they should connect
together how they should be operated
together how they be secured together
because the whole thing is about options
alternatives and capabilities and
enabling essentially the right
environment for the right use case and
the last century this is always keeping
the enterprise focused because this is
not about creating quick prototypes or
making things run in a small environment
but is essentially how to grow these
technologies in order to make them relax
and ready for enterprises with this I
wanted to thank all of you
[Music]